my name is Roger Mooney  welcome to Maria das ahora it's nice and  cool here in the summer and in the  winter it's nice and warm  JD babuji Boop I have many pairs of  slippers in various colors but because  I'm so small I prefer shoes with heels  slippers don't have heels is to us  Moroccans what wine is for Europeans  you'll find tea in every home we drink  it all the time for us it's like our  very own personal wine  I really like my house I like  maintaining traditions most people  prefer to live in apartments not me I  love these big rooms with high ceilings  and all the ornamentation plus the high  doors the doors and windows are from the  16th century we haven't changed a thing  I adore my King so I put his photo on  the wall here I hope I'll be able to  welcome you back to that suhoor another  time